[Applause]
thank you thank you so much for that
that very very generous introduction
um so I'm going to talk about how we can
reshape human AI interaction around
societal disagreements uh and you
demonstrate why this might be a good
idea
I think we need to look no further uh
than chat GPT just one really exciting
example of recent progress in human AI
interaction um
and so up at the top here
um in a natural language prompt um I've
asked it to write no to computer science
and already this is really cool so again
I work in human AI interaction where we
have these foundational visions of
Designing interactive systems
um in which humans and AI work together
to solve problems of empowering users
um to design and train their own AIS and
how we might trade off agency and
automation
uh but check GPT also highlights a
growing challenge in human AI
interaction which I focused on in my
dissertation research which is that
increasingly we are using AI for
problems where what qualifies
um as a good answer is going to depend
upon who you ask and to get at that
challenge I want to try a slightly
different prompt here uh which is write
and Ode to the most important sub area
of computer science
I mean so what happens here well uh it
begins uh o artificial intelligence how
vast and Grand I feel goblinson models
might give future yield and then goes on
from there
um now again I I'm a human interaction
research so I happen to think that both
HCI and AI are pretty important sub
areas uh so I'm not sure I'm totally on
board here and more broadly this is a
task for people might disagree about
what the right answer ought to be right
you and I might have different
priorities here
uh and that task for just one example of
how uh user-facing AI is increasingly
moving from a domain in which there was
sort of little to no disagreement about
what the right answer has to be to
domains in which there might be enormous
disagreements about what the right
answer ought to be so for instance in
medicine uh when Specialists disagree uh
there are entire tumor boards that are
set up to sort of discuss and debate
diagnosis and treatment approaches uh in
design closer to my own field
um different designers might have very
different ideas about what they are
ought to do uh you know if you're a sort
of Bauhaus designer you're thinking
pretty differently about a visual design
problem than someone who comes from a
different design school or in Social
Computing tasks like content moderation
or misinformation detection uh clearly
people are going to have very different
ideas of what acceptable behavior looks
like online
and in this talk I'm going to focus on
what I'm calling societal disagreement
so these are decisions that impact
multiple people or stakeholders uh in
the face of competing goals and values
where it's not just about what I want
but also what other people want so that
might be content moderation and we're
making decisions that impact uh the
health of entire communities it might be
creative tasks like designing a poster
or even designing this talk where I was
trying to reason over and optimize for
how different people in the audience
might respond to what I'm saying here
let's take content moderation as an
example used to address uh hate speech
misinformation harassment radicalization
even just enforce Community specific
Norms uh moderators research at
Engineers
um all want classifiers
for these critical social Computing
tasks that they can easily deploy at
scale
but in content moderation different
communities online can have vastly
different arms and values that's true
both across communities uh and that's
true within communities where Reddit
moderators disagree with each other on
29 of removed posts so when we're using
AI to help keep communities healthy
whose labels whose perspectives should
the model be emulating
today the existence of multiple
perspectives is largely sort of hidden
away or treated as noise and so as a
result AI often solves the wrong
problems behaves in unexpected ways
causing societal harm
um
but I think that rather than thinking of
this as a sort of problem for AI
we can actually treat it as a sort of
opportunity I think we have an
opportunity to create human AI systems
that help us adapt to New Perspectives
and expertise towards our goals
so how are we going to do that uh well
this is the kind of uh this is an
example of a kind of problem that I find
really interesting I think that the
exciting challenge of working in human
AI interaction is that to really make
progress we have to sort of bridge
design principles that we get from HCI
uh with the modeling realities of
machine learning it's not going to be
enough to Simply sort of wrap some
interaction around an existing model
like a black box and I'm going to get at
those realities of machine learning in a
few minutes but let's start with some
principles of HCI
in particular I'm going to build on this
idea of intelligence augmentation which
is a vision from the 60s of how machines
might help us solve problems by making
us smarter
and so how do we create those tools uh
well Simon and Norma talk about how
representations shape our thinking are
they shape what we consider problems and
how we solve them
and so in order to sort of reason over
the trade-offs and perspectives in these
disagreed upon tasks we have to be able
to represent them
and so fronting the power of problem
representation here I'm going to argue
that by embedding representations of
people in society into our interactions
and models and metrics that power human
interaction we can reshape AI into a
tool for a thought that lets us reason
over and evaluate models under societal
disagreement
uh and just to provide an intuition for
what I mean here we can go back to our
chat DBT example with this ode
uh today to create that system we'd
start with some data which we then used
to train a model which then produces
some output in the case I just showed
you uh that might be determined by the
annotator so did the instruction tuning
uh but now in this talk what I want to
do is sort of open this black box of
training data up
and articulate that there might be
a series of different perspectives
inside it
and then provide you with the tools to
actually control those voices and in
doing so change the behavior of the AI
so for instance you might care about how
undergrads or PhD students or faculty
might have written that out
and over the next 40 minutes or so I'm
going to sort of unroll that Insight uh
over the machine learning pipeline I'm
going to focus first on what we can do
in terms of the interactions and the
models that we're building
um to do that I'm going to present an
interactive AI architecture called jury
learning which enables developers to
explicitly reason uh over whose voice a
model ought to emulate
um through the metaphor of a jury and
then I'm going to ask what if we can't
change them all at the very least is
there something that we can do at the
sort of evaluation stage uh that helps
us become sort of more aware of the
problems the disagreement can cause I'm
going to talk there about the
disagreement deconvolution which is a
metric transformation
um showing how in in abstracting away
the individual people that models
emulate current metrics can dramatically
overstate the performance of many
user-facing ml tasks
uh well let's start with how we're going
to design these human AI systems that
navigate societal disagreement
and so to unpack what's going on here
what we do about it I'm actually going
to start at Ground truth so ground truth
is of course the stuff that we use uh to
train AI classifiers uh and it's
incredibly consequential because today
it's how we represent our goals and
values in these systems
so imagine you're training a model to
remove toxic comments online
uh should this training example here
which is making some you know aggressive
comments about pizza and politics should
that be an example of content to remove
or keep up
well that's a tough one it turns out
that in the public data set that we took
it from around half of people feel each
way about this comment
um and so in today's typical supervised
learning pipeline
we then model a sort of by aggregate
pseudo-human predicting typically the
majority vote label while ignoring the
annotators who disagree with that
majority
or maybe you could do a bit better and
it's either AI should predict say a 46u
distribution
but if you're a practitioner who's then
got to decide whether you're going to
remove that comment or not uh what do
you do with this information
there's not a really good answer here
other than other than just siding with
the majority
and for a long time that majoritarian
approach mostly made sense so you know
tasks like is this a cat or a dog I
would argue these tasks tend to operate
at the sort of perceptual level of our
systems uh there's not this sort of
higher level cognitive reasoning going
on so you know you're hopefully going to
say this is a dog otherwise I have some
issues with my my own perceptual systems
um but when this disagreement is
irreconcilable when it's endemic to a
task who we sample for the labels is
going to matter
but again today once we've chosen our
data sets annotators uh whose voice the
model that emulates is often left
implicit in that data collection and
training procedure and so if we can make
that voice explicit then we can Empower
practitioners to choose from and reason
over the decisions that different people
and expertise would make here
um so so what are we going to do here
are we going to do that well going back
to my thesis statement uh I think our
goal should be to embed representation
of this problem directly into the
interactions in the models
and to do that I'm going to introduce a
system called jury learning which is an
interactive supervised learning
architecture
um a technical and normative approach
that lets practitioners interactively
explore and tune and shift the behavior
of a classifier by explicitly
articulating uh which voices from your
data set the model emulates in What
proportion you would now specify a jury
it can be any size here I'm just drawing
12 because 12 people fit on the slide
and you say What proportion of that jury
should represent each group or an
intersectional identity that you care
about
and to make this interaction possible
we're actually going to sort of tease
this back apart such that the ai's task
is no longer to predict a single ground
truth but to take every annotator in
your data set or every
uh or juror here and then to predict
their individual responses and then we
can aggregate that as a result to create
a classification decision
and so this really sort of changes the
semantics of how the AI works the way
that we think is uh fairly
straightforward and interpretable
um and so the output of a system here
carries a different kind of
interpretation your traditional
classifier so essentially there's
something explicitly stating uh for the
following jury composition here I'm just
giving an example 56 56 of people agree
this comment as toxic and so now the AI
is being very explicit about whose voice
is listening to
uh all right so now just to give an
outline of where we're going here I'm
going to trace jury learning through the
following stages so first our normative
goals uh then interaction our technical
approach evaluation and finally some
implications of the jury metaphor and
opportunities
let's start here with our interaction
so why do we use a jury metaphor
uh well we wanted an interaction that
makes it clear that there's going to be
a group of individual decision makers
from which a single decision must emerge
and we think that a jury is a useful
metaphor for this
in fact what I want to claim is that
every data set already has a jury and
what I mean by that is every data set
already has some existing distribution
of annotators whose voices make up as
classification decisions
so in the example that we've been using
uh these five annotators here make up
its jury but
today this is an implicit jury it's sort
of baked into the training data and then
swept under the rug and so the
interaction that we've created uh is
really our version of a juror selection
process we want practitioners deciding
uh who these decision makers are going
to be in a way that's explicit and
visible and easily changeable
and so now let's walk through our jury
learning architecture uh for this
toxicity task and so given an input
practitioners start by defining a jury
composition uh selecting from anode from
characteristics in their data set so for
instance if a data set contains each
annotated political leanings uh the
practitioner might select uh for
instance two liberal jurors we'll also
choose here or two jurors who are
parental High School diplomas uh juries
can be any size
um here I'm just using four because four
uh work for this simple example
and so we now have these four empty
juror slots and we need to choose
individual annotators from our data sets
to fill them
and so we're going to start with all the
annotators in our data set again these
are all you know real individual people
and just like in any typical data set
they've each only annotated some small
subset of the examples in the full data
set
we can now filter to all of the relevant
annotators in our data set uh jury
learning currently requires that data
sets contain these explicit labels about
annotators
we can then randomly select a matching
your phone data set to fill each juror
slot
and the AI then predicts how each
individual juror would vote using all
the data that we have about their
annotations and the annotations of other
similar jurors giving us this jury's uh
verdict I'll talk more about the model
architecture that powers this in a
minute
and of course this can work with
regression two or you predict an America
instead of yes or no class
but now just randomly selecting one set
of jurors that's going to give you an
idea of what one particular set of
people might think
but jury learning enables something
impossible with real world juries which
is that we can actually resample our
jurors many times creating many parallel
juries
and then each parallel Jury has its own
predicted verdict
and so this approach actually results in
a direct measure of uncertainty which is
how often the outcome changed across our
jury samples we get this distribution
here of jury verdicts and each dot is a
resample jury
and then for a single final decision we
can take the median giving us a median
of means estimator
and to safeguard against
over generalizing a whole group's
opinions from just a few people what's
often called the atonistic fallacy the
system warns you that for instance if
you selected the characteristic doctor
but your data set only has a few doctors
you really first have to go collect data
for more doctors
and by modeling individual annotators
we've also enabled interactive sense
making about the nature of disagreement
so for instance we can plot uh where all
the selected jurors fall
among their whole population's
distribution helping us prevent the
ecological fallacy in which you might
assume that all individuals in a group
are the same
and so we can really ground the jurors
here as as individual people with
specific characteristics which enable
some some other explainability related
information as well
so you could for instance start with our
distribution here of juries
select then a specific jury
and then display information about a
specific juror which allows
practitioners to for instance reflect on
how that particular juror might have
labeled similar inputs in the training
data or look at that particular jurors
modeling error rate over all their test
examples
okay so that's interaction uh but now
walking back to this prediction step
how can we predict each anoterrous
response to some unseen example
what we're going to assume that we have
a typical classification data set each
of these jurors are again just
annotators uh and like a typical data
set
we assume that annotators have some
mostly disjoint occasionally overlapping
set of examples they annotated
and a bunch of training examples they
didn't annotate uh and of course we want
and of course we have this not just for
annotators that we selected as jurors
but for every annotator
and for every annotator we have a bunch
of characteristics
and then what we want is to predict each
juror's response to some unseen example
so how do we tackle this prediction
problem
well some of you might have noticed that
the structure is starting to look a lot
like a collaborative filtering problem
like what you use to create a
recommender system
so just like how Netflix decides uh
whether all like a movie because you
like a movie oh we might predict whether
I'll find a common Toxic by whether
people similar to me find it toxic
uh but we have one additional complexity
here which is that unlike Netflix
essentially every inference every
prediction is on a comment never that's
ever been seen by anyone in our data set
before
um every inference suffers from what's
often called uh the cold start problem
and now that is a standard assumption in
most classification problems you know
classifiers are designed to generalize
to unseen examples uh but in the
recommender system it means that we
need us to use what's called a hybrid
approach and rely heavily on content
features so to do that we started out
with a deep and cross Network which is a
hybrid architecture designed for sparse
web scale data sets by Google
um but given how heavily we needed to
rely on our content features it was
helpful for us to not just sort of train
our content embedding from scratch which
is what was typically done today but to
instead start our content embeddings off
with a pre-trained large language model
and then fine-tune that within the
recommender system from there so
essentially what this is doing is sort
of borrowing the same pre-trained models
used for classification NLP and then
integrating them into a hybrid
recommender system
and so on a technical level
how does that perform
well I want to start with one kind of
cool observation
so if we go all the way back to this
sort of traditional aggregated task that
we talked about at the start of the talk
where our goal is to predict this gray
label at the bottom it turns out that
our model architecture can actually do
that a lot better than a typical
state-of-the-art classifier
so the x-axis here is mean absolute
error the top bars for standard City Bar
classifier
the bottom bars jury learning lower is
better and so why is jury learning do
better here
well I think this finding highlights the
sort of hair and instability of the
traditional approach was that the value
of that gray label was really going to
change based on who the annotators are
um and so when we make predictions based
on who the annotators are and then
aggregate then we can do better than if
we try to directly predict aggregated
labels
so that's involved on technical side uh
but now let's talk about the user side
because really our motivation in
creating jury learning was that by
providing these levers by asking people
to make their values explicit you're
often going to get a more diverse
representation and who's making
decisions and that's exactly what we saw
in our field evaluations we recruited
uh 18 moderators from red and Discord
we gave these moderators um a jury
learning sorry we gave these moderators
a jury learning interface
and asked them to compose a jury that
they'd want to use in their community
and we can then compare the existing
distribution of annotations in our data
set what we've been calling this
implicit jury
to the juries that moderators chose to
create and what we can see here is that
for instance in terms of Razor
representation they certainly do
represent a much broader cross-section
of society
and these moderator composed juries they
behaved differently they made different
predictions uh than a standard
aggregated classifier and those
predictions changed for some of the most
uh contentious and divisive issues when
it really matters whose voice you're
listening to
we found that 14 of classification
decision change and these comments on
the edge cases these comments The Edge
are really important because
on behaviors in edge cases tend to
become de facto platform policies
so this approach also enables some cool
opportunities
uh for instance we can easily spin up
different juries condition of the
particular content or situation so
you know uh yes you could compose
different juries for different online
communities but you could also for
example compose a jury consisting uh
medical professionals uh whenever health
related content comes up
another cool opportunity uh
counterfactual juries uh so we can ask
if the jury that I composed says this
comment is toxic how much would we need
to change the jury composition by to
flip that outcome
we can set that up as a quadratic
program solve a little via complex
optimization and that allows sense
making on like
um well you know I thought given the
composition of this jury clearly they
would have found this toxic but they
didn't so what's going on here
uh all right and now sort of taking a
step back here uh Imports made clear
that while we view jury learning as a
step forward
uh it's by no means a Panacea it's gonna
create or sort of really bring
previously hidden problems up to the
Forefront
uh one challenge jurors can have biases
so for instance if you select a medical
doctor there's a small but non-zero
chance that you've got someone who's
spending misinformation about vaccines
uh our perspective here is that there's
really two orthogonal and complementary
World Views uh so today most approaches
assume that the world is broken and then
try to apply uh post-talk statistical
transformations to D bias model outputs
now what jury learning we're saying that
it could also be really useful to select
or train the people whose voices should
influence the model and
work in social science and HDI tells us
that it's often more tractable due to
the latter
our second consideration
who determines these jury compositions
uh well again every data set already has
an implicit jury what jury learning does
is make that fact uh explicit invisible
and easily changeable it's providing
this
new way to communicate and debate whose
perspectives are being included we think
that practitioners should make their
compositions uh transparent so they can
be discussed and debated
finally it's just important to note that
the straight metaphor is not an
isomorphism uh we wanted
again this crisp way to communicate that
there's a group of individual decision
makers from which a single decision must
emerge
then we have
some notion of a jury selection process
you know practitioners decide uh who the
decision makers are going to be but
there's definitely a tension here
between
what you're learning does today and what
juries offer uh in practice on legal
systems move that tension as as a
feature not a bug giving us a path to
reflect on uh the existing literature on
the biases and challenges of jury so for
instance
uh we're now working on tools and
methods for uh participatory
determination of the jury
we've also been thinking about
deliberation within juries
all right now moving forward I've been
really hard to see that over the past
year or so
uh since we first started publishing in
the space AI researchers are
increasingly rethinking disagreement for
instance AI researchers thinking about
misinformation and toxicity data
annotation evaluation approaches
explainable AI I've all started jury
learning concurrently we've seen new
technical approaches for modeling
individual annotators
but perhaps even more exciting to me is
that jury learning could also create new
opportunities in human computer
interaction uh so for instance in a
project led by my lab mate Michelle Lam
we were able to use the jury learning
model architecture to create interactive
systems for empowering end user audits
which you're seeing a video of uh now
and while so far I focused on content
moderation I think that this idea that
we can be designing interactions that
Empower end users to control whose
voices are models emulate I think that
extends uh far more broadly so
for instance if you're using a
generative artistic co-creation model
like Dolly and ask it to generate an
astronaut riding a horse it clearly
matters which artist which school of
thought the model emulates
another area translation while
translation is uh sometimes an exact
word for word match often different
people might translate the same sentence
very differently so which translator
should you model emulate
summarization imagine asking a
Republican versus a Democrat to
summarize a news article
uh even captioning an image for visually
impaired users these are all spaces in
which I think we can be designing these
new interactive systems that help us
make explicit uh carefully considered
choices about whose voices are malls are
emulating
okay
so we not only spend some time talking
about what we can do about disagreement
on the data
model interaction side
I want to move down this pipeline to
evaluation here
what does the style disagreement mean
for evaluation
and here's what I want to ask
so jury learning is this ambitious new
approach it requires rethinking how we
collect our data sets how we train our
models but what if the model is fixed
what can we still do about societal
disagreement when we're creating human
AI systems
I posit that uh one vital step is to at
least ensure that our evaluation metrics
are not hiding the user experience that
these models can actually deliver
and why is that important well my theory
of change here is that we will make
different product decisions if we
realign our performance measures
so how can we evaluate today's
classifiers under disagreement
let's start by talking about today's
metrics
so same example we've been using uh this
common toxicity task uh there are casual
competitions and so on
and if you look at the rocket you see
scores where 1.0 means it's perfect 0.5
means basically random these things look
like they're doing really amazingly
um you know 0.95 this isn't quite like
class grading but you know it kind of
looks like they're getting an a here
but in reality these classifiers appear
to be a studying contrast where on the
one hand we have our metrics telling us
that we're almost maxed out on this task
on the other hand we have Audits and
press articles and you know rni is
telling us that we're really struggling
that there's maybe a lot of users who
are not happy with how these classifiers
behave
and so it appears that something uh
implicitly perhaps is not being captured
here that maybe there is a sort of dark
matter that we're not observing and now
over 30 minutes into this talk you like
we have a sense of where I'm going with
this
which is uh disagreement specifically
that today's con metrics flatten
opinions into a single ground Truth uh
Lil per example
incorrectly ignoring disagreement
and just to give a super simple
demonstration of this let's say that two
people
so they comment was toxic and three said
it was non-toxic
metrics that aggregate via majority vote
would assign 100 accuracy to a
classifier that predicts non-toxic
but if we were measuring user-facing
performance we would never say here that
100 of users approve would report that
three approved the system response and
two did not
and so specifically what I'm going to
demonstrate is uh at that point nine
five rock AUC score is inflated as our
many scores and social Computing tasks
uh we're going to show you that that
specific score should actually be closer
to a 0.73 which is this much less
convincing number
and the technique got available to do
this is called the disagreement
deconvolution and the idea is that we
should be able to transform
any of today's standard classification
evaluation measures to better represent
uh how classifiers perform on your
disagreement so can we kind of create a
Twist that brings us closer to how HCI
has learned to evaluate systems
and how are we going to do that we're
going
back to my thesis statement here uh
instead of measuring predictions against
some aggregated pseudo-human we're going
to directly in better representation of
individual people into today's ml
metrics
and so intuitively uh what you'd want
here and if you agree with me thus far
this shouldn't be a very scary claim is
that
we should be comparing predictions to
each annotator's belief essentially
inserting one label per annotator into
the test set
so in this case uh Nava classifier
predicts toxic or receive a score an
accuracy of 0.6 because uh three
annotated agree with that prediction and
two annotators disagree in fact there is
no way here to get a 1.0 the best you
can do is 0.6 and of course we could
then compute almost any existing popular
metric using this new test set
and so essentially our approach is to
ask not What proportion of ground truth
labels does the classifier agree with
but instead What proportion of the
population does the classifier agree
with and our goal in doing so is to
incorporate an estimate
of how contested each label is going to
be into rml metrics in an interpretable
way
but now why do they say estimate here
well it turns out that this problem is
harder than it sounds in reality things
are a bit more complicated we can't just
take these labels as is uh there are
really two possible views of labels here
so fantastic image classification you
might expect that almost all the label
uncertainty is going to come from sort
of annotator error and then the right
thing to do is indeed to aggregate the
label across multiple annotators as a
standard today
and these more controversial tasks uh
you might argue instead that there is
you know no such thing as noise all sort
of disagreements in the labels is going
to come from unobserved features in that
case what we should be doing is called
disaggregation what I just showed you
where you don't average across
annotators at all so you then evaluate
models against all these individual
labels acknowledging that no model can
achieve this perfect accuracy now the
reality of course is going to be
somewhere in between uh these contested
tasks like toxicity clearly do include
variation from personal beliefs
but we also know that some annotations
might be noise uh there might be
misunderstandings uh lapses and
attention you know maybe your office
mate knocks on the door while you're
labeling data accidental clicks
essentially there is generally a
consensus that we cannot take label
annotations as strict face value either
and so our approach here is going to be
to try to remove these sources of noise
leaving only irresolvable disagreement
so how can we estimate whether this
agreement is noise or sincere beliefs
well we're going to start with a
simplifying assumption our idealized
model of the world is going to be kind
of a generative model uh we're going to
assume that each annotator has one
stable belief
and when an annotator label is an
example we assume that people will
generally answer that stable belief
their true opinion and that's reflected
in the labels that they're generating
but sometimes they're going to sort of
generate a different answer maybe they
more likely to sort of flip their answer
on really tough questions likely to put
less likely to flip on easy ones
essentially we're going to say that they
have
a certain probability of flipping away
from that stable belief conditioned on
the item and we're going to call that
probability p flip
and it turns out that if we know p flip
then we can resample a new test set by
adjusting the observed label
distribution as if they did not flip it
all
and while there's not time to get into
all the details of this approach I want
to try to give a brief intuition of how
we can find that p flip value
and so our key Insight here is that many
crowdsource data sets already contain
the data that we need and we've
developed a few different plug-in
estimators
depending on what the data looks like
so first we're going to use what's
called test retest data so crowdsource
data sets often do this thing that you
would refer to
um sometimes as inserting attention
checks where essentially you'll ask the
same question twice and then see if
people agree with themselves that's what
test retest data is
so now consider some imagine scenario in
which we had unlimited test retest data
in which we asked the same annotator the
same question an unlimited number of
times but we wiped their mind each time
we did that
well from that data you could then
directly observe pflip it would be the
disagreement rate with their majority
label
now of course in practice
this test retest data is not it's not
unlimited it's often quite sparse and so
the technical challenge here that I'm
omitting for this talk is how we
stratify and and aggregate
and that's spars test retest data
all right now second
if there's insufficient test retest data
for that
then we can actually set those up as a
collaborative filtering problem where we
essentially try to impute we try to
predict every annotator stable belief
and then we can measure how often an
annotators observe labels
disagree with these predicted stable
labels
and so what do we do once we have that
flip rate estimate that p flip that
estimate of the amount of label
disagreements arising from noise uh well
we can then use it to transform our
existing test set so for each annotated
item we can take here the empirical
frequency of annotate of annotator
labels in an adjuster for the effect of
noise this takes the form of a simple
noise level subtraction or normalization
to one
and then given this adjusted label
distribution we can sample labels from
it and treat these samples as
representing the noise free opinions of
annotators
and when we apply this what we see is
that many classifiers look way better
than they actually are when you account
for disagreement so problems that appear
solved in reality are really not uh so
again here is that state-of-the-art
toxicity from before
uh that .95 from the leaderboard uh when
we adjust it for disagreement we get
that 0.73 I was arguing for so you go
from your sort of straight A to more
like a c minus here
uh so current cellular toxicity claims
to be that 0.95 and our deconvolution
reduces to 0.73 the next thing I want to
point out here
um is that we can actually do the same
thing now but with what's called an
oracle classifier
and what that means is imagine you had a
sort of magic AI that always suggests
quote unquote corrected always guessed
what the majoritarian view is going to
be
well no classifier we're able uh we are
able to show will ever do better than
that 0.73 because even
if it's Oracle this magic classifier
always guess that quote-unquote right
thing
there's a lot of people who are going to
disagree with that and so it turns out
that on a technical level we are
basically maxed out on this task given
the inherent amount of disagreement in
the population we're never going to be
able to do much better than this
and across a bunch of other social
Computing tasks ranging from
misinformation detection to dual content
detection and so on we just see these uh
large drops um huge Corrections across
the board based on disagreement about
what the right answer ought to be
but in traditional AI tasks that are
again more perceptual uh like word
census ambiguation image classification
we got this much softer correction
because people tend to agree on what the
right answer ought to be
and so what I want to point out here
um is that even if we can't change the
model
simply by paying attention to
disagreements we can at least hopefully
really change how we think and that can
help us lead help lead us to design
better interactive systems and maybe
lead you to use something like jury
learning
all right now with that I'm going to
rest my disagreement case and so in the
two parts of this talk I've told you how
we um have these kinds of new
interactions can help with societal
disagreements how we can design
interactive systems that help us
explicitly reason over disagreement how
we can create evaluation metrics that
reflect the user experience that models
actually deliver
and there's of course more that we can
do here
when thinking about disagreements to
start to sort of loosen some of these
assumptions that uh our work has made so
far
so for instance you know people don't
always have a single belief they can be
uncertain they can hold conflicting
views uh disagreements aren't all
weighted equally you know think social
Choice Theory uh and there are new
tensions in data set collection here to
think about like how we balance clear
task designs uh while still eliciting
sincere beliefs
but really the point I want to make is
that more and more things that we would
think of as sort of human tasks uh human
judgment and subjectivity are now open
to AI systems so as we start moving into
these higher and higher level cognition
tasks we're taking these things that
traditionally people have done and we're
going to be navigating large design
spaces with many possible answers
and if that's going to be happening
then I think our point of view needs to
shift from just being right
to how do we use AI to help make people
uh to help people make smarter decisions
and so coming back to these foundational
ideas in HCI uh the real-line site
behind what I'm doing here is not about
disagreements per se
it's about sort of reimagining these
interactions and models and metrics
to create these interactive systems uh
that help make us smarter and so with
jury learning we reimagine today's uh
supervised learning pipeline as a tool
for intelligence augmentation that puts
different perspectives and voices at
your command and we adapted a jury
metaphor as a representation both in the
in the interaction and the model itself
and in the uh in the discrimony
convolution we reimagine how evaluation
metrics represent end users
and so Thinking Beyond toxicity
detection or jury metaphor is my goal
really in the large scale is to create
these human AI systems
that Empower us to adapt New
Perspectives and knowledge towards our
goals that help us sort of see beyond
our cognitive limits uh and put those
insights to work algorithmically for end
users and to do that I think we're going
to need to continue to really co-design
interactions and models and metrics
alongside human needs and I'm interested
in designing techniques for human
interaction not just for you know single
end users but when we're using AI across
many users across communities across
Society
and so what might that agenda look like
well I want to discuss a few different
ideas
starting with the interaction layer
how can we draw on the knowledge
embedding these models to help make us
smarter
to me the most exciting natural Next
Step here is in asking how we can not
just model the decisions that different
people would make but also how they make
those decisions so sort of a kind of
slipping on a pair of glasses could a
radiologist see what an oncologist would
notice about a CT scan could a student
designer see a gallery of how Bauhaus or
modernist or other designers might react
to their work I've actually been talking
to some doctors at UCSF who want this
exact capability
and so I'm excited to keep exploring how
we can model on other person's expertise
uh and create the interactive tools that
help end users learn from it
second creating a science of human eye
evaluation how we evaluate these models
is vitally important
and so how can we sort of overcome
today's false separation of concerns
between the technical performance and
the user experience they provide with an
interaction
I think there are two approaches here
one approach is to find sort of clever
ways to embed the ideas of HCI into
today's AI benchmarks I've done that
um
in the discriminant convolution I also
did that in a North paper called hype
which was learning psychometric
functions to evaluate generative models
that's one approach
the second approach is about how we can
take what we've learned about
user-centered evaluation in HCI and sort
of amplify that up to the scale needed
to iterate not just on UI design but on
models themselves I think a key to
achieving that is going to be
and creating formal methods around how
we can combine the complementary
strengths of human evaluations which are
greater reasoning over these you know
Point wise instances of quality and
usability and automated evaluations
which can reason over a large scale set
of models outputs
and then finally thinking about our data
sets and models one key challenge here
how can we discover the dark matter in
our data sets
so much like the jury metaphor
um you know borrowing a physics metaphor
here and the question is how can we
create tools that afford reasoning over
not just the existing data but all the
tools to reason over what's not yet in
your data set that dark matter that
hasn't been observed so for instance
let's say that you're using jacktube
it's a critique an essay
whose perspectives might be missing
from a data set used to train that model
and so the question here is how can we
couple human creativity with the power
of these recent advances and generative
models to discover and start to infill
these missing voices perspectives and
ideas
[Applause]
all right break out the vuvuzelas uh so
definitely a talk that Mitchell's never
given before sorry but that was my 15th
time good yeah so we have a few minutes
for questions comments disagreements
anything else
so um
with the disagreement decommission paper
what is your opinion about these like
goals that we should reach for so like
like you're saying like even with the
Oracle example like 0.76 or whatever it
was like the best you could do she'll be
like change what like we think as like
what the best is or what do you think
about that yeah that's a great question
so you know I think the kind of glib
answer here is well jury learning is
what I think we should be doing
um essentially you know what I think we
should be doing is given that there's
this disagreement we ought to First be
aware it exists not hiding it and then
second be able to make you know explicit
intentional choices about how we deal
with it that's sort of the the the
vision I'm trying to pitch here instead
of just hiding disagreement as we tend
to do today
um
thank you so much this is a great
defense yeah um I guess one question is
first of all you share this on toxicity
so do you do you really like require a
data set where you have like all these
different people's opinions and so you
can really do this fine grain selection
um of different voices to represent and
then also have you thought about how
like within a group there might be
diversity so like within the perspective
of like women there might be like a lot
of different perspectives and how do you
incorporate that
um great question so in terms of the
data set
um so back when we built this tool this
was sort of in the very earlier even
before the days of you know the general
models that we have now and so at the
time I think the perspective was that
yes we're gonna we need a data set uh
that explicitly collect data from
different groups or people that you
might care about that we can then model
now there's lots of recent work at least
trying to show that with what we're
seeing with these generative models like
chapter BT gpt4 Etc kind of embedded in
them somewhere different perspectives
and ideas and so I think that's still
you know an emerging space but it might
mean that we might need a lot less data
or at least a lot less sort of explicit
data and we can try to sort of
find these different viewpoints within
existing models um in terms of uh
different viewpoints in single groups I
think that's super important that was
sort of a key design principle in
creating jury learning and so for
instance uh we um don't just let you say
like there's you know one or two people
from a particular group in your data set
we're going to then you know put that in
your jury and model the opinion and
there you go we me uh we require that
you have a lot of people from each group
so that we can then model the entire
distribution of those people we have the
sort of plots I was showing where you
can plot individual people in a group
against the entire group to sort of see
where they fall in the distribution so I
think really important to have these
sort of sense making tools that make it
clear what the whole distribution of
opinions look like within a single group
um you talked a little bit about the
aspects of the jury metaphor that are
like not yet realized but you're kind of
thinking about like the jury selection
process I was wondering if there weren't
any parts of like a jury or the idea of
juries that you think are like not worth
incorporating into this like something
bad about juries like we shouldn't bring
into the modeling process
that's a good question so maybe just
first I'll briefly note that
um you know what what a sort of jury
conception looks like that clearly
depends on like the the legal system of
the country operating in et cetera so
I'm going to just talk here in terms of
like the Western legal system
um but there's a lot of great work that
has been done by you know sociologists
psychologists lots of folks sort of
getting into some of the challenges and
biases that that juries have
um I think one sort of
key thing that's missing right now is
Liberation so that's one thing I think
would be great to add but at the same
time that's also one area that can
really introduce a lot of sort of
complexity and bias and so to me that's
the area that's both the most exciting
and the place where you have to be the
most careful
yeah I'm curious what deliberation means
like are you thinking again of like
generative things where you would like
actually simulate conversations or is
like there's some abstract way of of
modeling deliberation uh also fine if
you want to keep that under your head no
no it's a great question in fact uh a
month or two ago I was talking to
someone at deepmind who was saying that
he was currently working on um
uh trying to have generative models take
on different points of view and
deliberate with each other uh now I sort
of you know the way that I Envision this
is maybe my talk would suggest is as a
more sort of
intelligence augmentation point of view
where I think there are really cool
opportunities to use these General
models to maybe help augment the way in
which we debate with each other
uh rather than just sort of saying two
models should go have at it and decide
for themselves
um but I think there's lots of cool
things to be done and sort of both of
those both of those directions
curious if you have any parting shots
for the grad students in the audience
having now finished your PhD advice
you'd pass on to the current students
the biggest advice has been already said
I'm going to say it again which is uh
for me it was so sort of important and
rewarding both like you know
intellectually and otherwise to take on
big Ideas
um
to take on these sort of big big
challenges and attempt to make sense of
the world and then execute on them
it can be kind of scary at first but it
was I think really worthwhile and I'm so
glad that I did it and that's what I
would suggest that a PhD students
thinking about doing as well
foreign
so Mitchell you showed us how with the
kaggle competition
um
the major artistic objective ended up
producing a model that did as well as it
could
um in a more disaggregated metric can
you describe the scenario where a major
artistic goal would reduce and it would
result in a classifier that does not
perform optimally on by that other
definition of success does that make
sense
um and so I what I was trying to show
with the kaggle thing is that we have a
sort of majoritarian viewpoint that made
it look like the model was performing
really well but in practice wasn't
um and so I'm not I'm not quite sure I
understand this sort of the point that
you're getting at the opposite of that
maybe so you told us
this model is not performing as well as
you think it is but then you ended up
showing us it's performing as well as it
can based on this other definition so
what's a scenario where it wouldn't be
performing as well as it could based on
your definition
um I mean
but that's a good question I think that
any uh you know if you could just use
like a worse version of the like like on
the calculator board go down the
leaderboard and find like a really bad
model and then that would be already
performing you know not state of the art
uh I think the the real answer is sort
of just like more and more complex tasks
that we're trying to do today
misinformation detection for instance is
sometimes sometimes considered the sort
of more High dimensional or complex task
so I suspect those models might be a
case we're going to see that but I think
that's sort of like a leapfrog game of
wherever models are not currently
performing optimally maybe they'll get
there eventually and then they'll start
to sort of really exhibit this issue of
their you know maxed out okay thank you
all right let's thank Mitchell first
thank you thank you